situado en los alpes a orillas del rhin
entre suiza y austria se encuentra el
sexto país más pequeño y al mismo tiempo
uno de los tres más ricos de todo el
mundo en una era de súper estados luchas
de poder entre grandes potencias y una
creciente centralización cuesta tomar en
serio a un país de sólo 160 kilómetros
cuadrados y 36 mil habitantes pero como
veremos el principado de liechtenstein
cuenta con algunas de las estructuras
políticas y económicas más
sobresalientes que podemos encontrar y
clank permitió alcanzar un pib per
cápita de aproximadamente 150 mil
dólares unas cinco veces en español su
sistema político es totalmente distinto
a cualquier cosa que hayáis conocido
antes y aunque muchas de sus
características sean imposibles de
exportar a cualquier otro país hay que
reconocer que les funciona hoy te vamos
a contar todos sus detalles
sí sé que muchos pensaréis lienchestein
eso es un paraíso fiscal y eso lo
explica todo sin embargo más allá del
controvertido debate acerca de si lo es
o no lo es lo cierto es que esta
interpretación de los hechos es muy
limitada y no se oculta muchísimos
elementos institucionales muchísimas
características particulares que han
logrado por ejemplo que este pequeño
principado consolide una economía muy
industrializada y con altas tasas de
innovación es verdad en casi un tercio
la economía depende del sector
financiero pero el 40% de la mano de
obra trabaja en un sector industrial de
muy alto valor añadido
que cada año genera un saldo de la
balanza comercial esto es de la
diferencia entre exportaciones de bienes
e importaciones de bienes sin tener en
cuenta los servicios de más de mil
millones de euros una cifra
impresionante para un estado de poco más
de 35 mil habitantes bueno es que sería
una cifra extraordinaria incluso para un
país 100 veces más grande un ejemplo
todo esto es por ejemplo bivalente uno
de los mayores proveedores de
equipamiento para dentistas de todo el
mundo que es de lynch stein exporta más
de 120 países todo el yen cheste no
resulta diferente empezando por su
monarquía que a diferencia de la mayoría
de las monarquías del resto del
continente europeo mantiene muchísimas
facultades y tiene un rol esencial en el
gobierno diario del principado de hecho
prácticamente podemos decir que el yen
chistine se conservan muchos elementos
del antiguo régimen
y la monarquía así mantiene por ejemplo
el derecho a nombrar jueces la capacidad
de fijar vetos legislativos o incluso de
disolver el parlamento sin lugar a dudas
la monarquía de alguien chiste es la más
poderosa de toda europa y por cierto
también la más rica la fortuna de la
familia real se calcula en no menos de
cinco mil millones de dólares de hecho
no cobran nada del principado y entre
sus activos se encuentran bancos y
muchísimas empresas pero claro este
sistema no implica que en dientes estén
no existan derechos civiles todo lo
contrario lienchestein es una de las
democracias directas más avanzadas más
desarrolladas de todo el mundo las
iniciativas populares son comunes y
apenas se requieren mil firmas o el
apoyo de tres municipios para presentar
cualquier proyecto de ley además los
ciudadanos tienen la capacidad de
movilizarse y votar para establecer o
suprimir cualquier ley cualquier
reglamento o incluso modificar la
constitución
de esta forma los ciudadanos de lienz
sting por ejemplo podrían suprimir la
monarquía mediante un procedimiento
perfectamente reglado y ya establecido
además todas las leyes que apruebe el
parlamento deben de contar con el plácet
esto es con el refrendo de la ciudadanía
de lienz y este y mediante referendos
facultativos
incluso los océanos del intestino pueden
determinar mediante su voto en
municipios que personas reciben o no la
ciudadanía de este país por supuesto en
lo referente a derechos civiles el
reconocimiento que de éstos hace la
legislación de este país lo convierte en
uno de los países más libres de todo el
mundo según todos los organismos
internacionales
y vemos la controversia entre una
monarquía con reminiscencias del antiguo
régimen y unas de las democracias más
avanzadas del mundo todo ello en un
diminuto territorio situado en el
corazón de europa por cierto del actual
jefe del estado es el príncipe hans adam
segundo un tipo también muy peculiar
porque a pesar de su papel como monarca
es un libertario de bandera un
libertario que propugna que tenemos que
ver al estado como un proveedor de
servicios cuyos clientes son los
ciudadanos y en todo aumento tiene que
tener la capacidad de buscar una
alternativa en el mercado privado o
incluso en otros estados y no están
satisfechos con los servicios recibidos
y creo que es un antiguo concepto en
algunas monarquías que eres tú que sirve
a la gente por ejemplo el príncipe de
inglaterra el príncipe carlos tiene en
su escudo de armas y tim la antigua
expresión alemana yo sirvo y creo que es
algo que tenemos que ver en el futuro
que la gente no sirva al estado sino que
el estado sirva a la gente como puedes
hacerlo lo mejor posible que tarea
puedes hacer mejor que nadie
así precisamente para estimular esta
especie de competencia y limitar el
comportamiento arbitrario de los poderes
públicos
el príncipe favoreció que en 2013
aprobar una enmienda constitucional que
otros
el derecho de secesión a todos y cada
uno de los 11 municipios que conforman y
existen así si los habitantes de uno de
los municipios de 16 no están contentos
con el encaje que tienen en el
principado o no están satisfechos con
los servicios recibidos pueden votar y
declararse estados soberanos o incluso
adherir a un tercer país algo
absolutamente inédito en todo el mundo
cualquier municipio tiene el derecho de
dejar el país pueden decir ok queremos
ser independientes o queremos entrar en
suiza en austria o donde sea en lo
referente a la economía y como buen
libertario que es lo que defiende el
príncipe hans adam segundo bueno pues el
príncipe defiende unos impuestos
reducidos y sencillos de aplicar y
comprender la privatización en la medida
de lo posible de las actividades y los
servicios que el estado ofrece la
liberalización de los sectores
económicos y el tráfico comercial la
atracción de inversiones y de
eliminación de subsidios
una política que a tenor de los datos ha
tenido en los últimos decenios un éxito
impresionante en el principado de
dientes de por cierto en el año 2009 el
príncipe presentó una obra titulada el
estado en el tercer milenio en la que
recoge su visión sobre el papel que han
de jugar los estados para generar
bienestar para sus ciudadanos y que es
muy recomendable para todos aquellos que
creen más que la iniciativa de las
personas que las decisiones de los burós
son muchos los que afirman que esta
visión está influenciada por las
particulares características de los
estados pequeños que a la postre suponen
un freno a la intervención gubernamental
pero cuáles son estas características
bien en primer lugar lo normal de un
estado pequeño es que su territorio se
encuentre próximo al de un estado vecino
de tal forma que sus ciudadanos conocen
lo que ocurren fuera de sus fronteras y
que en un momento determinado si el
gobierno les maltrata puedan tomar la
decisión de cruzar la frontera y
trasladarse a los estados colindantes
y es lo que podríamos denominar como una
emigración competitiva o incluso una
emigración disuasoria en segundo lugar
los estados pequeños no pueden hacer de
las políticas proteccionistas políticas
relevantes porque sus mercados internos
no son lo suficientemente grandes como
para abastecer sus necesidades de tal
forma que para cumplir con las demandas
de sus ciudadanos tienen que confiar en
el tráfico comercial
y en tercer lugar en los estados
pequeños los ciudadanos suelen ser menos
propensos a aceptar la redistribución de
la riqueza entre otras cosas porque ésta
les impacta de una forma mucho más
directa y además los gobiernos tienen
una debilidad mayor respecto a la mala
situación financiera lo que limita mucho
su ambición por gastar y gastar
por todo ello y en que este es uno de
los pocos países de todo el mundo que
carece de deuda pública su apertura con
marcia es una de las más altas de todo
el planeta que él insiste no hay paro no
hay corrupción y los impuestos son
reducidos precisamente en los
respectivos impuestos me gustaría
destacar su impuesto sobre beneficios es
un tipo único del 12,5 por ciento el iva
es de apenas el 8% y el impuesto sobre
salarios y rentas profesionales oscila
entre el 3 y el 24 por ciento es decir
unos impuestos moderados que no tienen
nada que ver con los que tenemos en
españa como los que son norma habitual
en europa
por cierto para incentivar la
investigación el desarrollo de
innovación el gobierno de 10 tienen
exención del 80 por ciento sobre todos
los beneficios procedentes de la
propiedad intelectual es decir sobre
licencias patentes diseños el resultado
es que el yen testing hasta el 7 por
ciento de su producto interior bruto en
investigación y desarrollo para hacernos
una idea españa sólo gasta el 12 por
ciento cinco veces menos
democracia directa derecho
autodeterminación
impuestos bajos libertad comercial y
mucha prosperidad como veis lynch stain
es mucho más que un paraíso fiscal y
desde luego es uno de los modelos que
más bienestar han conseguido generar a
sus ciudadanos bueno y qué pensáis
vosotros creéis que el éxito de james
stein tiene más que ver con sus
políticas que con su condición estable
cientos financieros queréis que podemos
aprender algo de este pequeño país
consideráis que este tipo de países
pequeños pueden ser importantes en este
nuevo siglo bueno espero que os haya
gustado el vídeo un saludo y hasta la
próxima